hagamos algunos problemas del orden de
operaciones y vamos a comenzar con lo
siguiente vamos a iniciar haciendo el 1
b y tenemos que es lo siguiente tenemos
que el 1 b es igual a 2 + 7 por 11 menos
12 entre 3 y recuerda que el orden
prioritario van a ser siempre tus
paréntesis aquí así que vamos a ver cómo
sería aquí no tenemos paréntesis pero de
mi lado derecho voy a poner el orden en
el que van siempre comenzamos con
paréntesis seguido de los exponentes
luego el siguiente orden será la
multiplicación y la división
seguido de la suma y la resta en esta
expresión no tenemos paréntesis así que
como vamos a comenzar y sería importante
que siempre recordarás este orden para
abordar sus distintos problemas así que
aquí la prioridad sería no tenemos
paréntesis no hay exponentes así que
vamos a comenzar con la multiplicación y
la división y estos dos pueden ser
equivalentes así que podemos primero
hacer la multiplicación antes que
cualquier suma o resta o nuestra
división antes de que cualquier suma o
resta y el problema 1 b es exactamente
equivalente a esto simplemente vamos a
estar reforzando la anotación y voy a ir
realizando la multiplicación y división
antes de hacer mi suma y resta así que
es 7 por 11 77 luego 12 entre 13 es
igual a 4 y el resto del problema es
hacer lo siguiente 2 más 77 menos 4 y
desde aquí todo es sumas y restas y solo
vamos a ir de izquierda a derecha así
que 2 más 77 y 79
y 79 4 será igual a 75 así que el
resultado del 1 b es igual a 75 ahora
pasamos al siguiente hagamos el 1 de
este problema resulta ser más
espeluznante de aquí por lo que dice lo
siguiente 2 por tres más dos menos uno
cerramos paréntesis y todo esto sobre
todo esto sobre 4 menos 6 más 2 - 3 - 5
y cerramos el paréntesis así que veamos
cómo podemos ir simplificando todo esto
un poco vamos a empezar con los
paréntesis pues ocupan la prioridad de
aquí dos menos uno es igual a 1 luego de
nuestro lado derecho 3 menos 5 es igual
a menos 2 o 2 negativo y luego por acá
estos paréntesis 6 más 2 es igual a 8 y
luego realizando como los segundos
paréntesis de aquí arriba 3
+ 1 que queda de esos paréntesis sería
igual a 4 entonces déjame reescribirlo
en color amarillo por aquí abajo sería 2
por esta expresión que es 4 2 por 4 esto
de aquí es 4 y todo esto sobre 4 menos 8
es igual a menos 4 entonces todo esto
queda igual a menos 4 y luego menos
menos 2
así que ahora sigamos simplificando todo
esto 2 por 4 es 8 y esto va a ser igual
a menos 2 x menos es igual a más 2
entonces 8 sobre menos 4 es igual a
menos 2 se preserva el signo negativo y
aquí este se cancelan y 2 quedarían
menos 2 más 2
el resultado de esta espeluznante es
espeluznante inciso nos queda igual a
cero ahora pasemos a los siguientes pero
antes de eso déjame limpiar un poco por
aquí para que podamos seguir
voy a quitar solo este espacio déjame
quitarlos y este pequeño cero que nos
quedó para cada para no confundirnos
entonces pasando en estos siguientes
ejercicios hagamos el 2 b el cual nos
dice lo siguiente 2 b dice que tenemos 2
y cuadrada torre cuadrada donde x es
igual a 1 que en realidad no es
importante pues no tenemos ninguna equis
y que es igual a 5 si el 5 de leyes nos
importa puesto que es 2 por que cuadrada
sustituirlo sería 2 por 5 al cuadrado
aquí como tú puedes observar yo ya puse
unos paréntesis y en realidad es lo
mismo que si tuviéramos 2 por 5 al
cuadrado sin ponerlos yo me adelanté
para poderlos leer un poco mejor y como
sabemos tenemos que empezar con nuestro
paréntesis o que es lo mismo que
empezáramos con los exponentes en
realidad no afectan en nada que hayamos
puesto esto y 5 al cuadrado es 25 y al
multiplicarlo por 2
el resultado es 50 entonces en mes
ejercicio 2 b el resultado es 50/50
ahora pasemos al ejercicio 2 de el
ejercicio 2 de que nos dice nos dice que
tenemos de cuadrada menos x y todo esto
al cuadrado donde x es igual a 2 y que
es igual a 1 y si nosotros sustituimos
esto podemos ver que en jeep ponemos el
1 entonces sería 1 al cuadrado
- x cuadrada perdón menos x que sería 2
y todo esto al cuadrado
todo esto al cuadrado entonces 1 al
cuadrado es igual a 1 - 21 menos 2 nos
va a quedar 1 negativo y eso lo elevamos
al cuadrado menos 1 al cuadrado que al
hacerlo nos va a quedar igual a 1 pues
menos por menos es más y uno por uno es
1 entonces el resultado en este
ejercicio 2
es igual a 1 y ahora pasemos a nuestro
ejercicio 3 b en estos ejercicios como
podrás darte cuenta también nos ponen
ciertas variables entonces tenemos lo
siguiente tenemos 4x y todo esto sobre 9
x cuadrada ah no perdón ese no es el 3 b
estaba escribiendo otro ejercicio el 3 b
lo que nos va a decir es que tenemos c
está cuadrada sobre x + más x cuadradas
sobre x menos g donde las variables x es
igual a 1 que es igual a menos 2
iceta es igual a 4 entonces ahora si
sustituimos estos valores en nuestras
ecuaciones en esta ecuación tendríamos
lo siguiente sería 4 al cuadrado luego x
que es igual a 1 más de que es igual a
menos 2 más x al cuadrado que es 1 al
cuadrado sobre x menos ya que sería 1 -
menos 21 menos menos 2 ya que va a ser
igual a esto para que va a ser igual
esto tenemos que 4 al cuadrado es igual
a 16 uno más menos 2
es lo mismo que tuviéramos menos 1 como
resultado más
1 al cuadrado es 1 sobre 1 - menos 2 -
por menos se convierte en más nos queda
3 entonces tenemos 16 sobre 1 más un
tercio a seguir haciendo nuestras
operaciones esto es igual a menos 16 se
preserva el signo menos más un tercio
ahora si quisiéramos hacer esta suma
tendríamos que tenerlo en fracciones
entonces podemos tener un común
denominador y a la hora de convertir el
16 en tercios tendríamos que multiplicar
16 por tres es 48 al dividir 48 sobre 3
sobre menos 3 se preserva y nos queda
menos 16 más un tercio ahora sí menos 48
más 1 sería igual a menos 47 el
resultado total de nuestro inciso 3b
sería menos 47 tercios menos 47 etc
y vamos a lo siguiente hagamos el
ejercicio 3d y el ejercicio 3d que nos
dice tenemos x cuadrada menos está
cuadrada sobre x por zeta menos 2 x por
z menos x y creo que si estoy
escribiendo el correcto verdad entonces
x es igual a menos 1 iceta igual a 3
entonces si sustituimos los valores de
nuestras variables en la ecuación
tendríamos menos 1 al cuadrado menos 3
al cuadrado sobre x por zetas sería
menos 1 por 3 menos uno por tres
- 2 x x que x es menos 1
por 2 - 1 iceta menos x que sería 3
menos
- 1 - menos 1 en realidad siempre que
tengamos menos x menos pues podría ser
un poco más sencillo que ya escribir es
un signo positivo y bueno 1 al cuadrado
que nos da uno por uno es 1 y menos por
menos es más entonces esto nos queda uno
menos tres al cuadrado es 9 y entonces
uno menos 9 es igual a 8 negativo o
menos 8 ahora vamos con el denominador
menos 3 por 1 es igual a menos 3 y
siguiendo el orden de nuestras
operaciones tendríamos que empezar con
los paréntesis y aquí sería lo mismo que
tener tres más uno este paréntesis se
convierte en cuatro y luego al hacer la
operación tendríamos menos tres menos 2
x menos 1 es igual a más 2
por 4 que sería 8 y este menos con este
menos se cancelan y entonces tenemos
menos 8 tenemos menos 8 sobre menos tres
más
8 menos tres más ocho sería lo mismo que
al hacer de la operación es igual a
cinco entonces este resultado es igual a
menos ocho quintos y bien creo que ya no
tenemos mucho espacio para continuar y
voy a volver a quitar esto para no
confundirnos
y vamos a lo siguiente ahora llegaremos
a algo interesante el problema 4 le
insertaremos paréntesis a la expresión
para poderlas hacer como una verdadera
ecuación y va a resultar fascinante el
inciso 4 b nos dice que tenemos 12 sobre
4 + 10 menos 3 por 3 7 igual a 11 ahora
veremos qué pasa si simplemente vamos
siguiendo el orden tradicional para
realizar operaciones y bien lo haré poco
a poco en mi cabeza para irlo
experimentando y en 7 hasta el 4 de
verdad si es que no quiero volverme a
equivocar así que vamos a hacerlo
siguiendo el orden empezaríamos con la
división que 2 entre 4 es 3 y luego la
multiplicación que 3 por 3 es igual a 9
y luego ahora vamos a tener sumas y
restas 3 10 es igual a 13 menos 9 es
igual a 4 más 7 es igual a 11 ahí
entonces si luce bien creo que llegamos
a un resultado coherente así que solo
hay que seguir el orden regular de las
operaciones y esto en realidad ya es una
ecuación correcta por lo que si hacemos
2 entre 4 como habíamos dicho más 10
menos 3 por 3 más 7 entonces nos sale un
buen resultado pero deja confirmo sería
3 + 10 - 9 + 7 y 3 + 10 por este lado es
13 menos 9 13 menos 9 esto es igual a 4
309 es igual a 4 y luego 47 en efecto
esto es igual a 11 por lo que no está
tan mal pues entonces aquí no será
necesario poner paréntesis porque esto
ya es una expresión correcta sino
simplemente hay que seguir el orden de
las operaciones y queda listo pero ha
dicho es paréntesis en paréntesis lo que
nos están haciendo es ayudarnos a leerlo
un poco más
pero bueno ahora vamos a trabajar con el
siguiente ejercicio 4 de tenemos 12
menos 8 menos cuatro por 5 igual a menos
8 si seguimos simplemente el orden aquí
la multiplicación 4 por 5 es 20 luego 12
menos 8 es igual a 4
y cuatro menos veinte no nos estará
dando el resultado y menos ocho esto nos
daría menos 16 entonces aquí perdón
borre el 8 aquí es menos 8 en este caso
si sería necesario ir poniendo
paréntesis para llegar al resultado que
queremos entonces déjame lo intento de
dos formas a ver con cual llegamos
digamos que tenemos 12 menos este
paréntesis ocho menos cuatro por cinco
si seguimos el orden las operaciones 8
menos 4
empezamos con los paréntesis 8 menos 4
es igual a 4 y luego al hacer la
multiplicación 4 por 5 4 por 5 es igual
a 20 y 12 menos 8 en efecto llegaríamos
al resultado a ver vamos a repetirlo lo
que hice fue poner paréntesis por aquí y
8 menos 4 es igual a 4 y luego 4 por 5
es igual a 20 entonces nos quedaría 12
menos 4 por 5 4 por 5 es 20
en estos paréntesis y 12 menos 20 es
igual a menos 8 pudimos poner también
aquí paréntesis para ir preservando el
orden de las operaciones pero de todos
modos nos va a salir el resultado y en
efecto esto es igual a menos 8 nos vemos